welcome everybody to the h3 podcast i
am your host the fresh prince of dead
air
with us today is tom segura and
christina p
the beloved couple of your mom's house
today's episode is sponsored by
quit quit quit quit
what's up how you guys doing hey hi man
how are you
very good um love
the setting what is going on here you
look like you were in a hotel
yeah it's basically it's our home hotel
yeah it's very sterile and emotionless
this is the only white in our house our
kids can't mess it up what's
what's new you guys are your guys
podcast is popping off lately you guys
all these shows
you guys are staying busy despite being
comedians who can't go on the road
no yeah you guys are still keeping busy
i know it's been so depressing not being
able to do stand up so we started doing
these live shows
right yeah tom really likes them because
i feel like it gives you the anxiety of
performing
it does and then like you know we we
hired a live content producer
and he worked at snl so he has like
oh on the show he gave us like the
rundown
with time and color and you start to get
this anxiety of like because this is
live you know and it's
and we have we had segments and we had
pre-shot
sketches and packages so we would go
between like doing the show
playing a clip interviewing someone
throwing to a piece we shot
and yeah it did give me like an
adrenaline rush that i haven't felt in a
long time
you know i thought it was great because
you obviously your guys shows
is very raunchy and i think one of the
great selling points of the live show
you guys put on the first time was it
was like
no holding back this time guys we're
going all
out yeah yeah and then it got it was so
raunchy and [ __ ] up that even the
pay-per-view website
was like did we have to remove this
on podcasts and social media which is
true
we have written emails where they're
signed off on the stuff they were like
yeah you're good to go there was no
surprises
nothing we would we didn't like throw
them a curveball it was
just that the president of the company
on the monday after the show was like oh
because we we did really well
what broke the sales record and they're
like check out this [ __ ] and then he was
like
no
well i had never heard of that company
so good job to that guy
i mean what does it matter what it is
which bit
is it do you think that put him over the
edge was it the
open bit the which one
well we had paris here's paris the guy
that put his balls in his ass
oh yeah so you guys had a guy put his
the balls in his ass and [ __ ] it out you
think that was what it did it
was not that guy but he
um put a rod in his ass he made a thing
that he could put something in his own
butt and then
we played horseshoes right yeah i saw
that
yeah and i think that may have been the
nail on the horseshoe maybe
maybe yeah it could be he's a horseshoe
fanatic and he's like these people will
not disrespect
my game they gain my life
aren't they the worst animals horses
horses
yeah i [ __ ] hate them why horses are
so beautiful when you see them up close
they're so majestic
they are majestic and then you get to
know them and you're like man [ __ ] these
guys why do you hate horses christina i
find that um interesting
they're like the communists of the
people world i don't
know
no i tell you why i don't like them
they're a [ __ ] smelly
have you ever lived near horses they
stink i haven't
when you sit on them they try to run and
kick you off
and they step on you when you fall down
under their shield the hell happened to
you
you know there's a lot of uh i've
noticed a lot of freaky women
like freaky older women are so horse
obsessed
and you know it's a sexual thing like
our first real estate agent she was such
a typical horse lady
and her whole and her other her license
plate was like my other car's a horse
and all this [ __ ]
and everything was horse related
yeah and um and you know
they must get off on the horse they have
a certain vibe that i don't know about
it
first lady questionable vibe yeah yeah
and one of our
first girls are [ __ ] crazy one of our
staff
ain't a horse girl and he was like oh
you don't know about that
horse chicks are real [ __ ] crazy and
uh he's like they're they're unstable
and they're erratic
like they're great and bad but he's like
now that i've had an experience
if i if i'm on one of the dating apps
and i see a
picture of all four of you yes yeah
you like if you if you even put a
picture of a horse
in your profile or a horse emoji or
anything you're in too deep already
yeah it's interesting i don't like how
people
advertise what they're interested in on
their cars anyways
yeah stan why are you wearing interests
or your political affiliation or
anything what do you want someone to
follow you home and be like i like that
too
you know what i mean what are we doing
that's so stupid no they're like or like
do you think you're going to get
business off of like your life your
license plate says i dock for you it's
like okay
i dock for you cool yeah
follow him home dude exit 5a oh yeah
my favorite exit is like exit five and
you're like what
tell me where you get off of the freeway
like yeah that's an insane so the best
thing that ever happened to me when i
started doing stand-up comedy
my mother had one of those custom frames
made to go around your license plate
and it said the funny honey
and interesting is so [ __ ]
embarrassing
and she kept pounding me and hounding me
and hounding me and finally i broke down
and i put the funny honey on like
[Laughter]
but it's true don't you think it's
so embarrassing
well you know my dad is one of these
people and i'll just go i like
telling my crazy dad stories on the
podcast
this one's [ __ ] crazy
he went to ucla like i mean he's like
he just turned 70. so it was literally
50 years ago
and he's still obsessed with being a
ucla alumni
that alone first of all is like major
red flags so people who are obsessed
with their college alumni
like who gives a [ __ ] right okay but
he's obsessed to another level he's like
a horse lady
for ucla so i don't know if you guys
know this but ucla has like a sports
rivalry with usc
huge yeah 50 years later he hates people
from usc
he and it's not like a joke it's not a
joke like he will not associate with
people
who went to usc he would disown me if i
went to usc
not kidding you think i'm kidding i'm
not but this that's not
the so he so all my life growing up
his license plate said h8s
hates usc oh my god and he had a license
plate holder
that was like ucla bruins now this is
now that's
we were cruising around all the time now
we're driving places
and occasionally you see other people
who want to show their affiliation and
support
for usc so when my dad sees these people
on the freeway he drives very aggressive
like i'll
never forget the whole family was in the
car we were going up the grade
towards la from ventura county you know
that big grade
yeah and uh he [ __ ]
he he cuts this guy off going like 70
miles per hour
with the whole family in the car and and
he's angry
he's actually angry at this man he
doesn't know because he has a usc
license plate holder and he he literally
just you know goes in front of him and
cuts him off so he can
and that's the story but he used to do
that [ __ ] all the time
i can't get enough of these back stories
i'm telling you mine i have anybody with
a wild dad
that's not on the podcast his dad's
stories were insane
bobby lee
i can't get enough of it well especially
foreign dads is your dad foreign eitan
no my dad is not he's he's very not
farmed
he's got vibes definitely got foreign
yeah yeah cause you could you better
bring that's
if you threw an accent on that behavior
i'd be like that checks out
perfect no i think he's just
dude i don't know how to explain my dad
man he's a different breed
sc trojans losers yeah he's a different
breed man
you guys you guys want to share any
dad's stories or no we'll just move past
this
fine you're dead my dad's too composed
i like that yeah he's very like you know
if somebody was
cutting him off doing that he'd be like
look at this guy
hate to be that guy
my father would have uh contempt for the
homeless
i remember oh well that's normal
i mean come on who doesn't
get a home idiot we were
that's old school that's like old school
[ __ ]
well yeah he's hungarian so like there's
a lot of gypsies in hungary
and they ruin um they ruin stuff you
know
wait like what okay i'll tell you
let's hear gypsy propaganda you know
it's funny because there's not really
gypsies in america you could just like
say all this crazy [ __ ] about him
and nobody cares everybody walks around
saying gypped but like that's like
saying
jude yes but nobody cares about gypsies
apparently
so hold on but the reason doesn't like
him so we had a friend in
hungary trying to sell their house and
just as they put their house
up on the market a bunch of gypsies
moved in next door
and essentially culturally they don't
work they don't want to work
and they steal and stuff they set up
like a food
fruit cart in front this is a good
episode
[Laughter]
they squatted they moved in next week
and they squatted in this house
and the guy could not sell his home for
like
illegally of his hatred no but my father
hated gypsies too because he said that
he used to see them
standing with their legs apart the women
would just piss in the streets
oh that can't be true
that can't be true all right
so are these are these stories told by
your dad
to you and you choose to believe him
i don't know have you met egyptian
wait you tell me gypsy women just pee
out their dress on the floor
is that tech is that possible to do
because i see i know you you girls have
to squat usually
well you can stand you can do it if you
don't give a [ __ ] about anything
yeah right i guess
i guess that's true of anything is it yo
have you guys seen i know
we have we have a lot of crossover you
guys like the goofy internet content
but so vin diesel's become a sweetheart
of our show
for a long time really oh you guys
aren't familiar with vin diesel
a song right no the not the song but i
am aware of the song
which is tr i mean is it the worst song
really i mean
is it really the worst song you've ever
heard i haven't even heard it yet
oh we'll watch it he he debuted on kelly
clarkson show and because they couldn't
have a live audience they had screens of
people doing this
you never seen that hold up
ian oh but ian first can you play uh
vin diesel can't stop uh praising
reporter
said over here come on guys
she's so beautiful i'm in love
what's wrong am i the only one that's
saying look at her
she's so [ __ ] beautiful it's like you
can't even do an interview with her
because he's just like
right wrong oh my god someone saved me
when did this turn into a beautiful
world
when did this turn into i love you thank
you so much
thank you very much there was no
interview that's it
how do you guys like that interview with
uh vin diesel
uncomfortable it's like i was just
thinking today back when i used to work
in an
office maybe in 2006 or something
guys used to just like your boss would
come up to you and just be like
how you doing christina oh no
no and like watching that
is what that feels like where you're
like i got it i got it
yeah i like the uh it's a very cool guy
tactic
to uh put it on other people like what
am i supposed to do yeah he's like guys
am i crazy
am i sexually assaulting her am i right
yeah we use those sound bites all the
time he was very telling too just
even i mean the end is obvious but even
during it you can see it in her eyes
she's like
okay well she wants she really wanted to
just conduct an
interview and then he's like all right
your time's up
she was not like yeah but his dick was
hard and she was making his deck hard
that's the other thing is you gotta give
him
you gotta give him permission like as a
guy if a girl makes your dick card you
should be able to say anything
i mean well it's
her fault he's making his dick what are
you supposed to do
yeah i think he actually would have
gotten further if he had been like hey
just
you know you're making my dick off my
dick my dick is like
is like semi i have a semi right now
and it's from looking at you baby
oh i love that interview man honestly
is there any woman on earth that can
resist that
first of all everything yeah i mean
i love that he's like a sex icon because
first of all the shirt
no sleeves yeah very plaid plaid no
sleeves
the voice he was was he drunk
yeah that's like that's i was up till
fire cocaine
baby yeah that voice was [ __ ] so good
yeah we use that all the time though
sound way so i'm glad you guys hadn't
seen that
yeah that was pretty good we try not to
let him live that down
ever here on this show it's my favorite
video of all time i think
oh i love this like like this is a
charming line when did i
come into beautiful world
i hope you've isolated that because that
is go ahead
women is turning the beautiful world
yeah well you know we did we picked that
thing apart
that is so smooth
that might be my second favorite line
after my dick's heart from looking at me
oh
hey hey i hope you don't like to find
the beautiful
it's a beautiful world with the pretty
kind of women
in the beautiful world
oh we have enough oh this song
this got me so hyped because we love vin
diesel
and then the fact that he oh actually
ian can you show pull up the picture of
him on the balcony smoking when he's
like super
chunky and his belly button's like mega
protruded
before we watch this because i want to
give the full vin diesel contact
yeah the way he like
owns that franchise right it does
yeah he does yeah
well i wouldn't be surprised if he has
like a big equity in it at this point
that's great because i'm sure yeah he's
rich
for a guy who as far as i know isn't
classically trained as an actor
how would you know that
i mean i don't i don't i don't suspect
he comes from the stage or the theater
you know he's good looking enough and he
oh nice
wow that's awesome
this was just a paparazzi shot of uh oh
he smokes i could explain the voice
yeah i kind of think the voice is cool
maybe i should smoke more
you like the boys
[Music]
that's awesome that's a good dude you
should start smoking more
i think it's funny that he got so fat
his belly button popped out
so anyway he made a he made a song
called
feel like i do and vin diesel do you
have anything to say before we uh play
the
the video
go ahead vin diesel vin oh he can't do
the soundbite
i'll do it for you yeah go ahead it's so
good
thank you okay go ahead
i hope you like it i hope you like it
thank you for the sweet words and before
we get to the music i just want to say
thank you look at the audience
it's our queen latifah sabrina carpenter
machine gun kelly
brenda gant and tyrell now without
further ado here's a sneak peek of vin's
collaboration with kygo feel like i do
that's his cover bro damn no effort at
all
good i mean he's cute though
what's happening with the audio oh yeah
i did
this is it look at this
oh that's all we got damn you gotta get
that
that song was amazing man that was that
was so good that could keep that's not
going to keep a gypsy from pickpocketing
you know what i feel like if i would go
into forever 21
like that's the jam i want that's mall
music music
hey hey ian will you do me a favor paul
that i want to get to take a look at the
faces of the people there's one guy in
particular i wanted to get a close-up on
uh he was in the back
and you know the producers were like i
want you to dance
he's gonna sing a song really move let
like let the music
just make you you know it's the truth
you probably couldn't even hear it
they probably here look let's let's
let's get a look at these guys groovin
they did some close-ups here go ahead
yeah let's see
oh yeah look at that they're lost and
they're lost in it
the guy in that white polo right there
he's pretty cool
huh feel that vibe oh there's a guy in
the red shirt that they do a close-up on
this guy in the top right
he's feeling it hard i like to get
audience with exactly like what a
pamphlet looks like for college
admissions you know
like you found an asian girl and then
put a black lady and then a couple of
white guys
diverse people that like kelly clarkson
so
yeah gotta kill to be in that audience
bro
why can't we to be able to witness that
live that
would have been amazing hey what do you
guys think
do um carol baskin was on dancing with
the star she got kicked off already
didn't she she was like
i think she was the first to go am i
wrong could someone fact check that
i didn't even know she was on but you
guys you guys are firmly believing that
she's a murderer right of course
[Music]
did you guys follow the news that that
uh her ex-husband
uh you know ex living husband
her his family took out an ad accusing
her of murdering him during the
first episode no dude
well we'll have to we have to play it a
television ad yes
it's like the [ __ ] game it's like
game of thrones [ __ ]
she came on dancing with the stars she
was there for one episode got voted off
because she's horrible
and in that episode the family surviving
family members of her husband who she
allegedly killed
ran an ad basically insinuating she did
it
incredible stuff wow that's cool
i would love to see that yeah pull that
up
that's unbelievable i know it's a it's a
great story here they are this is
here i'm gail one of don lewis's
daughters
we are a real family and to us he was
daddy
i'm linda one of don lewis's daughters
and we miss
our dad i'm donna i'm don lewis's oldest
daughter
we need to know what happened to our
father
i'm ann don's former assistants
all we're asking is justice for done
don lewis mysteriously disappeared in
1997. his family deserves answers
they deserve justice do you know who did
this when carol baskin was involved
100 000 reward has been funded you can
call the tip line
at 646-450-6530
or call our office at 800 litigate thank
you
they ran that during the episode wow on
abc yeah
yeah yep that's why they spent some real
money to get that
yeah well he was rich apparently so he
must i wonder if he left the money
i love how his his secretary was in
there that i was like
i was like well we could have cut it
we're all in the dock so i'm sure they
were just trying to like prop
put the faces that people recommend oh
the secretary was in the dock
yeah yeah i didn't watch this closely
oldest daughter in there because she was
the hottest yeah the hottest the oldest
dog
[ __ ] during the commercial donna
talk to me baby when did i turn in the
beautiful world
whoa not like this
when i saw donna yeah she was just one
of all the dogs
she was the oldest too which is
interesting that is interesting the
hottest and the oldest
what happened there i think they let
themselves go the younger ones
if i had to guess frankly hey ethan
we're at uh 30 if you want to throw it
to break
okay we got to go to commercial we'll be
right back
when was the last time you got rewarded
for brushing your teeth with quip's new
smart electric toothbrush good habits
can earn you great perks
like free products gift cards and
more you've probably heard us talking
about quip a million times
but there's something brand new that
rewards you and your mouth
quip smart brush for adults
and kids connects to the quip app with
bluetooth
it tracks when and how well you brush
you get tips and coaching to improve
your habits
and you are important you earn points
for daily brushing
and bonus points completing challenges
like streaks dude i would crush that
i wonder if there's like a leaderboard
where um
i can compete with my fans because i
feel like i crush it on the brushing
no cavities one slight one when i was
seven but look
ah you see anything can you do that dan
wow nothing
i'll cry one of you won me on quip smart
brush
that's the new street challenge uh
that's pretty cool there you go
you get rewards and stuff do you already
have a [ __ ]
quip well upgrade it with a smart motor
and keep the features
you already know and love you've got the
sensitive sonic vibrations
the two minute timer with 30 second
pulses which guide you
and clean your teeth slim light weight
look at this
it's it's it's feather featherweight
sleek no wires no bulky charger to weigh
you down
multi-use travel cover boom
all right no boom
that also doubles as a mirror
oh you can put it on your mirror it's
got this really adhesive
goes right on your mirror yeah it is
incredible
it is versatile it is amazing
um beyond the brush clip has everything
you need for a cl
complete routine they've got mint or
water melon toothpaste with anti-cavity
ingredients for strong healthy teeth
they got floss that expands to clean
and comes in a refillable dispenser to
reduce waste
plus you can get brush heads toothpaste
and floss refills delivered
from five dollars and the shipping is
always
free now how smart is that
five million brushers can't be wrong
that's a lot of quips
save hundreds compared to other
bluetooth brushes
and get started with quip smart brush
for just
45 dollars god damn
start getting rewarded for brushing your
teeth today
at get quipped dot com slash h3 right
now and get your first refill
for free that's your first refill free
at get quip dot com
slash h3 that's g-e-t q-u-i-p
dot com slash h3 quip
better oral health made simple
and rewarding
[Music]
and we're back all right thanks for
sticking around
um oh i miss you guys so much can i just
say i miss seeing you too
yeah what i miss is um ethan's self
flagellation that's good i always feel
it when i'm around the house and i
like drop something all right in this
place like i chastise myself the way you
do
it really it makes us laugh that's it
like when you're going the [ __ ]
stupid
yeah i do i play it i don't think ila
finds it funny though
i feel bad when he's like that but i'm
joking
that's because she loves you but yeah
but like i guess i guess i should laugh
at it
well only if you think it's funny
no i i do find it funny i think you guys
are the only ones that find that funny
actually
we really enjoy because what happens is
i'll go
i'll do something i'll be like i [ __ ]
up again [ __ ]
me and then nobody laughs and so i
do it more yeah and uh they don't ever
laugh at it
right i think they just think that i'm
ha that i'm unstable
yeah yeah yeah that's right
when i see unstable people
yeah it makes sense um i do think it's
funny how much you and christina are
like the same person
me and christina yeah you guys are the
same
you texted me that wow what's going on
what do you think yeah well you said why
don't i
i i won't say it because i don't want to
say it but she said something that was
like so much like you
oh why don't you say it i wanted to go
somewhere and she didn't want to go
yeah and she was like i'd rather [ __ ]
kill myself oh yeah
oh yeah and that's like you whenever i
want to do anything it's like you'd
rather just
die than do it well is that just was
that the specific event or
you don't like doing [ __ ] it was an
event
that would put me under it was too much
effort
for what it was yeah i'm saying i'd be
like well
i don't want to do all that to do this
thing
yeah you know what i mean it's hard
enough to leave the house like
let's not complicate [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's no
much effort do you ever just be like i
bet the baby wouldn't wake up if we left
for three hours
you know i think so and and they make
monitors that you can take like the nest
app you can take on your phone and you
can see the baby sleeping theoretically
anywhere
yeah so yeah you should be able to go to
the phone
i leave town and i'm like he's sleeping
yeah i was like i was like man we could
probably go
[ __ ] for a drive get some dinner see
movies
what's the worst that could happen how
was the kid now
he's almost uh he's like 1.3
years oh oh yeah you get it
a couple nights you can go away
are we back dan uh yes oh and we're back
we cut something out we said something
we that was too
[ __ ] up and we cut it out for the web
just be honest
yeah we'll have to save that for the um
too hot for telos
what was that so it was me that was you
two oh i thought it was a sound like a
soundbite
all right what else we got i've got
current events you guys
i love it salt bae one was kind of
stupid i'm gonna be honest with you guys
we've got a story about salt bae
someone got in a fight and he filmed it
for tick-tock
i've been admiring your admiration of
tech talk you've been
oh yeah throttle and i'm glad welcome
well i'm yeah i resisted for a long time
because i thought it was just underage
girls dancing
but it's so much more than that it is so
much more
it's really in a peek into the mind of
the deeply deeply disturbed
right i mean i'm i'm i'm
always and you know like if you
drink alcohol i mean actually i have
some of my choice ones
because what i've been doing is i've
been
kind of trimming my own for you page
like a
perfect bonsai to serve up the weird
[ __ ]
to me and i'm amazed how often
i get [ __ ] with like two likes on my for
you page
right yeah it means you're doing good
work that your algorithm is pure
and so every time i get a really weird
one i share it with you guys
and so i just went and and nabbed some
of my favorite ones
i can't wait i love it so go ahead
uh ian go from the weird from ethan's
homepage
and and and uh i wonder if there's
overlap ethan between
our selection yeah there could be but
but
that's okay [ __ ] it no i mean i i like
to see where your mind goes
and well the titty guy the titty guy
i've seen the titty guy on your show but
i didn't know that he was on tick tock i
didn't even know you could make that
content on tick tock
the guy with this titty torture oh god
yeah i
saw it on your show slave norm yeah yeah
and i just
saw him on my homepage like what the
[ __ ] i wonder if that's
new posts pull up slave
norm this has 33 000 views
i think someone's putting it up for norm
i don't think norm curates his own
well regardless i just find it funny
that tick tock
found it suitable for me to watch this
here it is this is from good morning
everybody
this is slaves
[ __ ] you dude don't clickbait slave
titty norm
[ __ ] this guy get this [ __ ] off my
screen now
all right let's watch fatty ready for a
nap this is
without a doubt the weirdest [ __ ] one of
the weirdest things i've ever seen
served up on my for you page 3 000 views
which is equivalent to 150 likes
oh my gosh
fatty ready for a nap y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it is thoughts
well i've seen this person's work um on
the tone
and sometimes for me i don't like when
they're too
self-aware is that what it is i think
this one she's
uh just literally it's a costume it's a
mask
oh
yeah i like that in my feed i i get
upset
when i sense funny or weird i'm like
it's
great when it's the genuine thing i
thought it
i mean this video has 150 likes i mean
really what are we distinguishing here
between a guy
who's doing this to be weird
and putting it on tick tock you know
what i mean he's not getting attention
he's just that yeah true
well but it feels deliberate like it
feels like
i know all right i have 22 go ahead this
one is
is actually very popular coming in with
let's see
i like this yeah look how he hydrates
look at that
good that's a big one damn
he's still chugging what a g what a
glizzy gobbler
you gobble glizzies tom i gobble
everything yeah
sure i'm 22. this has
uh 12 000 likes how 20 yeah here you go
this is
indian are you oh i'm 22.
oh you older than me now i'm
22
we are the same age but you said you're
22
yep i'm 22.
i'm 20. hello yeah yeah
you know about him hey tom
you're not going to steal that bit are
you
it's very clever it kind of reminds me
of the stand up you see
in emerging countries you know like
uh where like where it's new like
whether like they've never had
and then that can i see thomas christina
what's happening
thank you i was yelling at my staff oh
it's okay
yeah but um it feels like foreign vibes
you know
talking about foreign foreign funny yeah
well you guys might be happy to know
that
let's see i mean i guess we should watch
all of these i think i think
let's go through this list but then we
actually put together a whole list of
foreign tick tocks
oh nice i love the foreign talks those
are so hard to come by especially the
indian kind
but when you find them they're so
special i like the the
indian wedding ones where the women are
crying on their wedding day
and they're like you know um
okay it's the cold weather you're
supposed to pretend to be crying on your
wedding day oh
fascinating well here should we finish
these ones um let's see we've got
i could watch these all day girl gets
turned uh oh no i don't want to watch
that one
crazy dude warning everyone that they're
going to die
i think i know you're going to play you
know
like you saw all of them but it's very
obscure i mean i'm talking this video
has 4 000 views
which is probably viral for his channel
anyway and 300 likes
is this your boy uh he rants a lot
on the talk i have a hard time i have a
hard time with him because he's so
frantic and there's so many talks he
puts out
he says dana mary god herself has
released
mega massive catastrophic cataclystic
apocalyptic
underrated under natural natural
hazardous disaster events gahadian
this is on my homepage
why cause you didn't love one another
and you didn't ride in james eugene
england jr
for the 46 percent of the united states
of america because we're gonna kill you
i almost give you [ __ ] what happens here
dino whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
it's like all these days you know i just
look around and see the world and go
[ __ ] what's gonna happen to them and
they didn't learn to love one another
but me
oh god i'm crazy as [ __ ] man
there's some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that
i've been saying on this tick tock
i've been seeing some [ __ ] that people
got going you're out of your mind
hey look tweet of these and tweedledums
are done their shitty job
you know they're like wharf rats you
know what's your
friend you want to listen to but i guess
the point that i'm trying to make about
tick tock is that
i can go from you know
someone doing like a cute dance to that
and a swipe it's just so unlike youtube
very strong meth vibes like yeah
meth i think maybe i i think if you're a
meth addict you don't survive that long
do you
well you can or maybe he's like 30.
yeah he could be 30. but i think he's uh
he's pushing through
with his it's definitely mental illness
too yeah i think it's mental illness
the manic vibes there yeah it's very
apocalyptic in nature he's always
telling us he's predicted this and that
interesting good find though yeah thank
you
work well here let's show the poisoned
uh poisoned poisoning your girlfriend
this comes from uh turkey or india
it's a trend where they pretend to
poison
someone but then then you get poisoned
it's wild
it's very popular too show them with 2.9
million views
very popular then to poison someone yeah
oh wow yeah
here we go
so yeah we're gonna have to watch this
again for the play-by-play they killed
that [ __ ]
poisoned her how's so so so she
poisoned him yeah it's kind of it's
complicated
it's a deep plotline lots of poisoning
she gets poison i don't know and they
were actually in on it
stupid [ __ ] people like it though
this says 3 million views so oh i'm
confused
you know i find these um these
the the eastern world talks yeah they
have they they also like
a lot of schmaltzy cutesy stuff the
indian
ones are also very cutesy cuzy uh but
this is dark
and i this is actually a dark talk i
have not witnessed something
there you go yeah it's a it's an
assassination of broad daylight
oh here's another dark one a dude
literally
uh assaults his girlfriend for glancing
at another guy
but it's it's it's portrayed like
gloriously like this guy's a pimp and
she's a [ __ ]
so i don't know what country this comes
from turkey probably
yeah he's like [ __ ] she's like she
literally just
she literally just glanced over at him
and he [ __ ]
possessed yeah he's like uh uh girl you
don't [ __ ] look at
anybody except me he's a health he's
he's a model man yeah
that's dope dude
that's how you train a woman right yeah
sure is
a real man when we walk
yep i don't think so
yeah we like to look at [ __ ]
um in our neighborhood they wear those
lululemon pants around here with their
clothes
and tom's always breaking his neck
looking at those
ladies but then i like we like to look
at their camel toes as long as you turn
it into something positive
yeah he points it out she'll be like
tommy where she goes look at this girl's
[ __ ] over here
would you have looked at it if she
didn't point it out i had
missed them she notices them way more
you should be like
and christina do pointed out you want to
draw
tom's attention to the camel toe i mean
it is funny
it's funny but i feel as though like he
probably wants to look anyway we've been
giving him permission to look it's a way
to be like
look at that chick over there i don't
want you to have to not look like a
horse with the blinders on
you don't have to be like turkish alpha
male who but
who wwf body slams you and you it should
be pointed out that i endlessly
endlessly tell her to look at guy's
dicks you know
whatever that guy's doing
christina do you i've recently become
aware of this phenomenon
i there's like this thing
this is from tick tock i saw they're
like oh it's gray
sweat pants season because apparently
you can see dude's dick outline
and gray sweatpants yes you can is that
a
thing that you follow no i haven't seen
that one yet you and i have
a little different algorithm no but do
you do that i guess is my question
oh yes uh there one time in old school
that we sent our son to there was a dad
who wore sweatpants every day
israeli israeli really and
biggest sticker had the biggest dick and
he just wore pants every day
and it was like it would it was such a
distraction and he's sitting there
because we were walking in with our
everyone walking with their kids yeah
they're kids
year old kids two and three year old
kids and
and it became a thing among the parents
he was like
he was like small in stature too which
is like kind of funny also as he's like
five eight you know five seven
140 pounds and just the most enormous
hog on him
like it was ridiculous do israeli men
have
bigger dongs i think i
i mean obviously i don't
you know you look at charge base you can
see charts and they go like penis size
based on geographical location have you
seen those
no we told we told
nadav who who works with us about it
and we were like oh yeah we found out we
didn't know you know who he was or his
bad
like israeli and nadav goes that checks
out and i was like
he goes like he goes the behavior of
yeah i got a big dick that's your
[ __ ] problem
it's israeli that's that's very
true yeah i think that's that's true
funny yeah israelis are the worst man
talk about
i mean i mean in a weird roundabout way
are we kind of
praising the work of
i mean adolf hitler i mean we're coming
out against hit
gypsies and jews and i think
like very positive spin-offs
i mean if we could really summarize this
episode
you know killed you killed the jews in
the gypsies
but that's true sweatpants are a great
way to see
do you like that though or do you find
it like kind of for a reason man he wore
them every time that's the thing i find
that to be really
like disgusting that you're like that's
weird i gotta show my dick
outline off but do you find do you like
it christina or do you find it kind of
gross
tom and i before kovan used to go to the
laker games
and we had these the laker games tom and
i used to go see the lakers
okay you're in la and you know
it was nice because we had these lovely
box seats up up above but
at the same time i like to see them
running in their shorts
because that's the fun you know what i'm
saying oh
you see things oh so so you've got your
eyes on a different ball
set of balls yeah compression shorts are
we tough yeah wait how could
this be jacking around and be playing
basketball at the same time
ela do you look at dick outline i don't
think i
don't think i've ever been to a game not
in basketball just in general dude look
at dick outline
um i feel like when when you guys
mentioned it i feel like i have seen
that person like who will
just wear yeah maybe it is israeli i
don't know i have seen that happen no
there are dudes that do that
but do you look for the dick outline
it's a little distracting
not a good thing i don't know oh but
it works i feel like when i saw it it
wasn't people that i
it wasn't the right concept disgusting
not the kind of people that i want to
think about
yeah that's a good point but i like it
when tom wears
uh dick shorts i even call them dick
shorts around the house because i like
to see
a little outline yeah but you know what
yeah you know what i'm gonna say when i
wear like gym shorts or something
without
underpants it looks like a [ __ ] like
acorn it just shoots straight forward
you know what i mean it just looks like
a little bump it's just like it's not
flattering
at all and i'm not and you know yeah my
penis is horribly small but it's not
that small
but it's just the way it rests sometimes
it depends on the weather obviously
i like to say that my dick is small but
it gets smaller
you know like if you put me in the right
situation it'll start going inside
so pretty cool when you wear your dick
shorts
i get to see the nice outline when you
walk around the house
i like to see it there was the time that
i wore i bought
i didn't i didn't have swim trunks and
we were on vacation
and i went to the like the shop at the
resort
and i bought white board shorts that
were
completely see-through
that's awesome i love that
yeah but i i am surprised by how much
camel toe you can spot out in the world
these days you know it's like
some pictures the next time i send you
but i will say that it's because of this
lulu lemon craze
of these women in our neighborhood they
love to just wear the lululemon pants
around yoga pants
yoga pants without a shirt covering and
it it accentuates your vagina well you
can see everything
what mommy sorry mommy
i said you could see everything you can
see everything yeah so
she wants they kind of want you to see
their vagine and
everything i mean i don't wear my
lululemons around because i don't want
people looking at my junk
yeah i would wear a long hair i never
really got it i don't know
in israel fair game you're allowed to
say something compliment her on it
hey nice [ __ ] how insulted would they
be but at the same time it's like
why are we not just talking about that
the elephant in the room or you know
exactly you know
thanks for wearing that thanks just be
like hey thank you so much
have a good day
just start doing like this when you walk
by
[Laughter]
i like it um
i don't get it i feel like in israel
women do it too
and here it is just wear it like
as if you're wearing pants you just wear
like
yoga pants but i i strongly believe
that looking in 20 years from now
looking back people will
remember the yoga pants craze as like
the crate one of the craziest fashion
trends of all time
you know yeah because it's just it's
just ass and vag
out for everybody all the time it's like
wearing a pair of tights
out in public as pants it's like tight
exactly
that's what it is and pull up a picture
of the flesh-colored uh
tights please
in the meantime why don't we get bikers
like you know cycling shorts
but like white or cream colored
real tight just walk around in those for
a while dude i would look so bad can you
imagine
oh i would look terrible because it just
well let me show you what it looks like
it's it's
it's incredible yeah but i mean can
i mean theoretically
i don't think society would like dudes
walking around
with dick outlines most of them would
not
i don't think the world's ready for that
these people are squares
you know what i mean those people aren't
comfortable you want to see just dicks
with the male
mel phallus i see phalluses everywhere
like the kid from from my life yeah look
at this look at this [ __ ]
you see this this is what i would look
like and
tights is this the best thing ever
that's what most people look like i mean
but the flesh colored man
it's the best yeah
like that's what i would like the thing
is about dick is like
i feel like any size boobs any vag
like generally if you're fit everything
looks good on a woman
yeah but you can't be walking around
with like little dick in a
tights that's just not a good look why i
appreciate all sizes i like to look
no matter what i just like to look i
like to see what people look like
that's true i do too i think it's
interesting i'm not wearing any shorts
but i like i don't care what society
says
i'm keeping my dick tucked away where it
belongs
you will never see it uh ethan will you
please wear those
not even ela sees it
not keep it dark
can we please buy can i buy you those
nude
i would wear i would wear those yeah i
would definitely wear
those i'm gonna get
those are those lululemons i'm gonna get
those nice and tight
for christmas nice and tight uh what
else we got
girl pretending to faint i mean who
really gives a [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] this [ __ ] stupid i'd
rather just talk to you guys
i have all this dumb [ __ ] but it's just
not that entertaining
what'd you guys think of the debate
excellent
america went again not to win
you know honestly i think you walked
away going we got two the two best
these are the two best guys trump 2020
am i right i'm on the train
i love it four more years man it was
great
yeah really inspiring i guess i was
inspired
oh we have yeah we have a compilation of
all the uh
the reporters after the the um
debating like that was a national
embarrassment
that was a train wreck that was a dump
it was fire so bad
it was one of the worst things you know
i feel bad for biden though i watched
the whole thing and i and i was just
like
i mean i really don't know what he could
have done
you know yeah and it's hard well you
know
in the past like they've almost always
pretty much stuck to the you you agree
to
rules for doing it yeah they just threw
it out the window immediately
yeah well they need to get tougher
on trumpy uh make the rule if he
interrupts
that you get your mic cut boom and then
the other guy gets a minute
there you go or or trumpy if you
interrupt your mic is done
it's like i mean this [ __ ] was like
watching you know a brawl it's like come
on man
i'm trying to actually hear people
well you know i heard an interesting
analysis is that
trump doesn't have much to say or
insight on actual
policy so when he can derail the
conversation
that benefits him and when actual
conversation takes place
that benefits biden who's obviously been
in office for a long time
this weird thing that happens too it's
like there's a pattern to a lot of these
things like at the
end when they were talking about the
ballots
and you know bidensting was like go vote
vote
send in your vote and then trump's thing
he's been pushing this
this is going to be the biggest fraud of
all time and
and you know they both the moderator
chris wallace and him were like you know
there's no
proof of that you're making this up he
just doubles down on it because he knows
there's a
segment of the population that'll just
buy that there's
massive fraud when there isn't and
there's no evidence
plus it's a red herring then he gets the
media to talk about him
talking about the ballot stuff he's like
look guys we found
eight ballots in a in a pool of water
did you just call it off we got a cover
thing
that was hilarious with uh kaylee where
the
journalist was like um hey so trump said
that they found ballots in a river where
which river where's the river she's like
i think you're missing the point here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god
and she's like you're missing the forest
for the trees he's like what are you
talking about
i love it direct question it was just
like there was another
you know it was indicative of the way
that administration
kind of acts you just say things and
then you don't have to
answer for them yeah it doesn't matter
there there was a great moment from the
press secretary actually today he she
goes
they're they're trying to get the new
supreme court justice through
and she's like she's a rhodes scholar
she was saying that do you say that
and then and then the journal says like
uh there's
she's not a rhodes scholar and then she
looks at her notes she's like excuse me
she went to
rhodes university in maine or some [ __ ]
like
oh yeah oh yeah yeah like she goes
my bad yeah my bad my bad
i'm surprised she didn't argue it
further yeah i noticed you got a little
political on twitter lately tom what's
going on you uh just
lost have you given up no i mean like
i don't you know i'm gonna go pc real
quick okay oh i know
you know okay ladies check out hang on
hold on hold on
what's that hold that thought okay the
ladies are gone
what do we talk about no don't cut it
dan this is the guys only club
what are we talking about is she pissing
you off how you doing
man these [ __ ] [ __ ] we gotta do
something [ __ ]
[ __ ] them i wish they were [ __ ] yoga
pants
no square as hell
though what how great would it be to
have a big dick
yeah i don't i don't think i've made her
come once
it's like my my whole arm is too big and
my penis is too small what do you do
use your mouth man what are you talking
about
you're what you're what what is that
i'm back oh hey what's up yeah
oh did she go yeah she's taking longer
hmm
interesting what does it mean
do you take a dump ela no you took
longer than christina
how did you do it so fast i pushed
really hard
you're like a [ __ ] gypsy just peed on
the floor you stick up
do you brown you don't brown in front of
each other right
we do i mean i'll take a [ __ ] in front
of you i don't care
yeah i mean like with the door open i'll
talk to her while i'm taking a [ __ ]
yeah i do it regularly um thomas i do
not wish i would
i wish you would talk to me while you
were sitting oh you're like are you one
of those guys that's like
i know people i had a friend who like if
he's [ __ ] he'll pretend he doesn't
exist
yeah that's what he does he's like if
you're like hey tom
if you go like hey tom it's like he
won't even answer you
that's what he does why why on fire and
he just ignores
me tom tom can you and just ignore why
tom
why that's my time i wanted that one
but isn't it rude to not even answer to
acknowledge her
oh that's what's rude that's what's rude
it's not bothering me
i love you do you jerk off or something
what are you doing in there
i i mean i just i'm meditating um what i
don't understand that you sh you [ __ ]
i know we have the same toilet okay so
you [ __ ] you click a button
maybe you're on tick tock you're jerking
off in there aren't you
i've done it but not not not awesome it
smells bad
i after think ethan that my emotional
needs are greater than his i'm very
needy
i i want to talk to you while you're
shooting i want to cuddle
ew no no no huh you said cuddle no
i like cuddling so but not while i'm
locking the door
i'm not answering you i'm with tom now
no not not while he's
not wild oh okay okay okay not sitting
in his lap
i'm a dog i'm very needy i like to what
are you doing
let's play i want to cuddle i want
affection and he's more like a cat
lately
lately you guys having marital problems
what do you mean lately
but i do want to cuddle with him and he
always says that he's too hot
to cuddle and it's true
well cuddling is kind of dumb when you
like actually realize that like
it's cool when you're like hey we're
dating and it's fun and then we cuddle
and i get a boner and then
one thing leads to another but like as
an adult
we've all been married we have kids i
don't cuddling is
for [ __ ] virgins
thank you yeah like and she's like can
we cuddle
and it not lead to sex and i'm like no
oh my god you married a guy
you know if you want to [ __ ] just
talk about [ __ ] marry a girl
you married a guy yeah you yeah i don't
know about all this
well go ahead you have a voice we do
cuddles sometimes yeah we do but like
not like
like it's we cuddle like we put our
heads together
but i don't like being like constantly
touched i get uncomfortable
or like we'll spoon for a little bit but
not like sustain not from
yeah for a little bit yeah but like if
i'm watching a movie i'm not gonna like
spoon her the whole movie that's crazy
no i want
i wanna sleep in a spoon no oh yeah no i
can't fall asleep like that
no do you do you know i
actually am having flashbacks to college
when i would like
have new relationships and then you know
you're supposed to cuddle and [ __ ] and
so it's like
you you're spooning a girl and she falls
asleep and you're just like
how [ __ ] and i'm so uncomfortable and i
there's no way i'm sleeping
and i'm going how long before i can
try to escape from this and it's like
miserable it's literally miserable yeah
and those were the best
times in my life miserable
is that what made you so i comfortable
a little spoon like a cuddle yeah and
then
not not for sex and just and then i'll
be like okay i'll start to go back she's
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh where are you going okay yeah
i'm i'm good with like just the little
cuddle and then and then i'm done
too thank you
i like to go head to head like if we're
on the couch chile one way i'll lay one
side and maybe we get like a head rub or
something like that i like head
scratchies that goes a long way with me
now that is currency
ethan loves that see you're the same
person
stop with it just because i don't want
to
i don't look at dick outlines like her
maybe you do
and i just don't know you look at dick
outlines
i just found out today yeah but eitan
would you look at
badge outlines if you saw the lululemon
guys just let's just i feel like i would
look at it just
from like the fact that it's like there
i don't think that i get much out of out
of cameltoe frankly from like a sexual
satisfaction point
of anyone no i mean i well sure some do
but like camel toe itself is not
but it's like yeah i mean i would look
at it sure
wow so when you guys
use the bathroom you close the door
yeah he closes the door and then it's
like no one else exists like you said
and then i re-emerge a new person
yeah but i i'd be willing to have a
conversation through the door
like i and wouldn't in our case the door
is always open
so yeah not even closing the door
sometimes theodore comes running and
sometimes you know shredder does this
funny thing where he
when he knows you're going to take a
[ __ ] he runs in after you
[Music]
because when there's people here like
our housekeepers here
and i close the door of course shredder
runs into the bathroom before i can
close the door so he can be in there
with me while i [ __ ]
um that's cute i like it when the dog
comes in
that's nice when there's an audience
there and i i don't mind it when my kids
are
there now i'm so used to two people
staring at me and the dog
i like an audience when i [ __ ] i like to
shut the door
yeah we gathered that tom
get out of here go [ __ ] with your mom
try to take his [ __ ]
so i think tom wants his own wing of the
house like i think that
would you have your own bed tom
[Music]
no actually i sleep horribly no we sleep
well together
yeah but i do think that tom requires
a dad den like a dad
area just to put his dad's stuff
in like a dark room with no light
because he doesn't like sunshine as much
as i do
and somewhere to wild out you know like
his
his space don't you agree yeah that's
true
all right that'll wrap that'll do it
all right we love you guys so much thank
you for having us
thank you guys hang in there don't i
think we're almost through this you know
just another
two or three years
at vaccines baby uh
all right trump 2020 guys take care keep
america great man keep america great
all right bye guys